il est rentré dans ma maison nous avons
pris l'apéritif il me regardait encore
évidemment ça je voyais bien qu'il y
avait une certaine attirance on s'est
fait des confidences alors ce ce soir et
naturellement il a rrêé son train et
tout ça pour rentrer chez
lui j'étais marié 18 ans que mon mari a
été tué à la guerre et alors j'étais
veuve très jeune mon premier mariage a
été une perfection d'amour de tendresse
de de tout ça été un déchirement pour
[Musique]
moi alors recommencer une autre vie ça
m'a semblé assez difficile comme toutes
les femmes il y a quand même quelques
occasions plus ou moins
valabl actuellement je suis seul je
n'aime pas être seul évidemment la
compagnie d'un homme est toujours plus
agréable je ne suis pas portée pour
vivre avec une dame
22 mais j'ai quand même la
compagnie dont j'ai fais la connaissance
comme ça la compagnie une compagnie
comment dirais-je platonique et non je
sais pas comment vous dire moi voilà une
compagnie d'un homme très aimable un
monsieur de la campagne que j'ai
rencontré comme ça avec lequel j'ai
parlé et puis après qui est venu me
rendre
[Musique]
visite
j'adore la mer et la plage tous les
jours j'allais sur le front de mer
àoyant en robe de plage j'étais installé
sur un transat là sur la plage comme ça
tranquille seul alors un jour comme ça
dimanche je crois c'était oui j'étais
toujours installé comme ça les gambes
enfin comme on est à la plage quoi
derrière je je vois une présence un
monsieur j'ai dcelé tout de suite que ce
monsieur était un homme de la campagne
par qu'il m'a parlé il m'a dit il fait
beau madame comment on dit vous savez
bien les choses banales dans les
rencontres il avait quand même l'œil sur
moi il me regardait beaucoup au bout
d'un certain temps il me dit voulez-vous
qu'on aille prendre quelque chose j'ai
refusé tout net bon ensuite il m'a il me
questionné énormément où j'habitais ça
ça ça le il voulait savoir où j'habité
alors j'ai j'ai dit j'habite Paris
puisque j'ai toujours habité j'ai un peu
menti là
le dimanche suivant je m'installe je le
vois naturellement alors là la confiance
était déjà un petit peu mieux il est
encore reparti il avait un autobus à
prendre fallait qu'il parte à l'heure il
me dit au revoir comme ça je vous
reverrai sûrement au'hui c'est possible
c'est très
possible mais alors quand il est parti
il faut que j'aille voir si vraiment il
va prendre l'autobus je l'ai
suivi bon j'arrive à l'autobus
effectivement je vois ce monsieur
alors d'un seul coup spontanément je lui
dis voulez-vous prendre un verre à la
maison chez moi j'habite tout
près donc il est rentré dans ma maison
nous avons pris
l'apéritif qu'est-ce que vous voulez là
il me regardait encore évidemment ça je
voyais bien qu'il y avait une certaine
attirance on s'est fait des confidences
alors ce ce soir il a raté naturellement
il a raté son train et tout ça pour
rentrer chez lui mais il est parti quand
même il est parti je ne sais comment
mais dans la semaine il est
revenu bonjour
hen ça fait 2 ans maintenant que je
connais je m'attache à lui j'ai une
grande tendresse pour lui un grand
attachement parce qu'il est très bon
très gentil immeuble ma solitude de
temps à
autre
j'ai vu que c'était un honnête homme
j'ai vu qu'il avait des belles maines
[Musique]
travailleurs je suis toujours contente
qu'il vienne me voir il me fait une
sécurité
[Musique]
morale
c'est bizarre la vie vous savez je vois
qu'elle éta dans elle est belle plais
elle le sourire puis plais elle était
bien physiquement belle femme j'avais
l'idé
dealler la
voir toutes les femmes plaisent un peu
bien sûr mais dans pourquoi moi plus que
d'Ar par terre sur la plage à côté de
nous il y en avait des quantités ah oui
de
dames alors c'est pas moi qu'est-ce qui
t'a pris à ce
moment-là je saurai jamais je sauraai
pas
ça
bonjour bonne nuit bONJ as-tu bien
dormi et l'hiver quelquefis ben j'étais
un peu souffrante il m'a un peu soigné
un peu tenu compagnie l'été je le vois
moins parce qu'il a ses travaux des
champs ses blés et cetera alors il vient
très peu PRP le café ah je veux bien
c'est il est comment dirais-je je peux
pas raconter des affaires impossibles
enfin c'est un homme non il sera pas
toujours à me caliner à me caliner comme
certains hommes avoir des petites
attentions non c'est pas ça non pas
exactement et ben il aurait peut-être
des désirs assez précis
parfois
passé de semain comme des
amour nous avons pensé 15 jours de rêve
diraiton de rêve oui oui enchanté et
nous avons l'intention de recommencer
cette année à
Nice cbire ça me
plais
pas
liberté tranquillité voezv c'est ce
entière liberté moi-même li d'aller que
je veux une vieci chez moi lui il est
très indépendant il aime ça ses allés
venus oui oui c'est pas un homme qui se
fixera chez une femme mais oui mais dans
le fond de tout il est moderne dans le
fond de
[Musique]
tout